Hello, I'm Jad Abumrad, I'm Robert Krulwich. Today on radio lab,
our topic is the music in our heads. How does it get there?
Where does it come from and why won't it go away? Yes. No,
you think that the music you listen to is your music.
It comes from the place you live,
but there is such a thing as everybody's music.
And we offer the next story as a kind of proof comes to us from reporter Gregory
Warner, Gregory Warner. You won a journalism fellowship and they said to you,
you could go anywhere in the whole world. Where did you decide to go?
So I went to Afghanistan. Have you ever been to a war zone before by any chance?
Yeah, I mean I've, no, but have you done any international reporting before?
Well, actually earlier that year I had been in Astonia covering and accordion
festival. So that was a, a prime piece of, uh,
so you play the accordion? I play accordion.
Do you like that an accomplished accordionist? No, no, no, no.
I'm just an amateur. Accordionist okay. So when you go to Afghanistan,
do you bring your accordion with you? Yeah, I brought my card.
How does that work out? Well, I show up in Afghanistan.
I'm carrying my accordion and I'm thinking maybe this wasn't the smartest idea
because it did. It wasn't an accordion playing crowd. I mean,
I was coming down the street and women in Burkas are holding their babies and
little boys will actually sob, sob, begging you to sort of buy a piece of gum.
Here I am with my shiny red accordion and it's just not very appropriate.
Does there come a time when you're actually willing to use the accordion? Well,
it was a weeknight and was in my living room.
They find the jeep who's my fixer and translator, he's working for me.
He's lying on his back and he's flinging his legs up into the air.
A guard is catching his legs and flinging the back down. Well,
this is a kind of Ab crunches. That's what we're listening to now. Yeah,
there he's throwing his legs up. [inaudible] pushes him back down, going up,
back down. So I figured I'd help him out.
So I started playing my accordion for him.
[inaudible]
it's going well. The Jeep's bopping his head too,
and then he kind of looks at me. This is [inaudible].
How do you know Afghan music?
I see I'm not playing African music. And he says, yes, you are. I say, no,
I'm not. Yeah you are. I said, no, no, no, that,
that's like folk songs from the 60s called. Those were the days my friend,
some song that my, my mom used to sing.
Oh, so [inaudible] is my friend. That's my mom.
[inaudible] we'd sing him dance forever and a day.
He says, no, no, that's an Afghan Afghanistan.
And then he's back to the app crutches and I'm like, no, no, no way.
Wave it to please tell me the story of those were the days my friend.
So what's the story of a, those were the days my friends,
that's what we call it. Tell me about that song.
[inaudible]
talking as from all senior who is famous for being the classic Nova.
His name is [inaudible] feminists and Guy Gudnason.
It's 25 years ago, but not [inaudible].
Then Paul showed them time. [inaudible] done house for them. Done. Huh?
[inaudible]
wait, wait, wait. That's not [inaudible]. Okay. It's true.
He did get it wrong, so I forgot about it. I thought he was crazy.
Then he kept happening. I would bring my accordion played for some people.
Every time people would say, hey, isn't that an homage to your song?
How do you say, oh, how do you spell this name? Z. A. H. I. R. I'm e. Z.
Who is he? Well, that's what I wanted to find out.
So the first thing that deep gave me was his entire CD collection and one night
I sit down and listen to it. I'm hearing one western riff after another.
John Lennon, Nat King Cole. Definitely a lot of Elvis.
Like I realized on this tune
[inaudible]
isn't Ahmed's at year two you can actually overlay the Elvis version.
No,
right on top of it.
Is he stealing these tunes? Is that what you're saying?
It's more like he Afghan eyes them like here's one of his biggest hits.
Don Harstad them ton
[inaudible]. I'll show them time [inaudible]
hey, you remember this is the song that the jeep sung to me,
but it did sound familiar. So I emailed this tune to an old friend at St Louis.
He immediately said, Oh yeah, that's that western disco hit lb.
Ah, that's a daisy. This is the Western version.
It's the same melodies. Ahmed's a year version. Same Keven.
Now let's just go back to the Ahmed Sayer version for a second.
Listen to this by Linda [inaudible].
This is east meets West. I'm and say your style.
And this is like the mega hit in Cabo 1973
this is the sound of Afghanistan.
[inaudible] yeah.
So I begged the chief to tell me more, but this Ahmed's say guy.
And finally he says, okay,
I'll take you to meet the old childhood friend of the man himself.
So we drive up to this gate. This guy with white hair opens the door. Whoa.
In a jeep chat for a bit. [inaudible] said that dark,
dark said that died down. He's been friends with them.
It's been here since the fourth grade and he takes us inside.
He closes the gate behind us, the scene changes. Suddenly it's a garden.
Birds are chirping and then sit out,
stops and he points to this old fountain in the courtyard and he says something
in the jeep and the jeep starts laughing and jeep says, you know,
this is the fountain where Ahmed Z or used to play his cordia
Zaire plays accordion just like me. They're saying that a force,
the girls were lying down there and he was playing accordion here,
you know 40 girls, 40 girls.
Oh they, they did call them Casanova for a reason. What was that? Okay,
cause in Afghanistan maybe girls and boys aren't supposed to like be hangouts
because Afghanistan was a pretty different country in those days.
It's something I didn't even realize until I got there.
This is the 70s the women are wearing skirts and Jane Fonda haircuts.
The men are wearing sideburns and they're doing their James Dean and it's not
just what people are wearing,
it's that there's this sense of possibility in there that things are opening up.
Finally, and the poster boy for all this is almond Sayer.
He's a bad boy that I'm even going go on with the pitch and Nami Poma they can
have the concert. Everybody,
all the girls would come to his concerts.
We are in new clothes and not on all the girls of Afghanistan,
but the foreign girls, they also weren't in love with him.
Let me just play one little clip from one of his shows and I want you to hear a
little screen that comes right in right here.
[inaudible] for young Afghans at the time, especially young African women. Um,
it's a year. He was like, God, what does that accomplish?
No, mother will give birth a child to as good as [inaudible]
and this is where the story gets a lot darker.
It's 1973 the Russians start to move in and the new president that they put in,
he doesn't really like him. It's like year at all. Why? Well,
it was really in their interest that Ahmed's a year would come out publicly
praising the government and he always refused to do it. Anything political,
he wouldn't play the show. And some of his songs,
especially the later songs started to actually have coded anti government lyrics
in them. Oh yeah. Yeah.
And then he would have other lyrics about how freedom is the most important
thing. So what did the government doodle? They ban his songs from the radio.
They start throwing him in jail kind of regularly,
but even when he gets out of jail,
he refuses to play any of the communist party event.
But he plays plenty of his own shows. In fact, after one concert,
he meets this beautiful woman named for Hero. The way she tells the story,
he taps her on the shelter. He says, Hey, says hi. Can I talk to you?
I turned my face. I said, yeah. He said, no, never mind.
He tapped you on the shoulder and he said, can I talk to you? And then he said,
nevermind. And he walked away and he just walked away.
That was pretty good seduction technique, I guess. He was very good in it.
You got some guns like that and he got hurt and they got married, right.
And she got pregnant. Meanwhile,
the political situation was getting worse and worse.
All his friends are fleeing the country.
There are murders, tortures. Somebody came to our house, knocked the door,
and he said, can I talk to Ahmad site please? Ms [inaudible] offered him,
can I get you a drink? I said, no, no, no.
I've just come from the Ministry of Interior. There's a plan for you.
I don't know what they're going to do to you.
That's all I want to tell you to be careful, but I'm
say you're in his wife. They don't do anything. They don't. They don't leave.
Why? He says, oh, we'll go after the baby's born. Five days later,
it's his birthday. June 14th,
1979 he's actually signing a contract for a concert that they went to sign a
contract. As he's driving away, he tells her to make some lunch.
It wouldn't be come back.
We'd go shopping and then I will make Lasagna and then we'll go out.
So she makes Lasagna and she waits for him to come back and she waits and then
she falls asleep.
I had a very weird dream.
I'm somewhere very high in the mountains and I have no shoes and there's a very
strong wind blowing and my hair is everywhere. I,
I see him, not the way he went in the morning.
His beard is out,
like he hasn't shaved for past two days and he has something white around him
and something is pulling him.
And he's calling me that I don't want to go.
And second day I woke up, I ran down, I saw my father in law.
He wouldn't talk. He was just bending the know,
like shaking himself and bending and just holding my hand.
I didn't know anything. What, what, what happened? So what happened then?
Well, the government says that, um, it's a year, had a traffic accident,
but everybody else tells me he was shot in the head,
probably by government operatives and the news spreads through all the
neighborhoods in town. So you have Tajiks, poshed tunes,
Uzbeks they're all getting up and not really knowing what else to do.
They come walking to Ahmed's Edgar's house,
the courtyard starts filling up with people. 5,000, 200.
They're inside the house. They're outside that has,
they're on the street at this point.
The body comes Bourne by six policemen on a stretcher.
People start to whale, they start to push. In fact, all the windows break,
the doors break.
They bring the body through the courtyard into the living room and for here
pushes through the police and she sees her husband's body on the stretcher.
So I thought he was hurting,
does something. And when I pulled the sheet from his face,
that's when I fell down on top. And when I fell,
they took me to the hospital and that's how [inaudible] was born. So
does she go into labor cheap? She goes into Labor right there. Yeah.
And she almost dies in childbirth. Yeah. But her baby saved.
She saved and her baby has the same birthday.
Then her baby was born on that very day. That very day.
[inaudible]
what happened was then the music basically stopped.
It's that winter that the Russians and invade starts a long period of war.
You have the jihad, then the mujahideen and the civil war.
When the Taliban come in, they just band music
entirely. I mean, no instruments.
We're talking 20 years where the cultural life of this country,
basically, it's frozen.
I can't even imagine what that's like.
I can barely go a day without hearing some tunes.
2001 the Americans come in, Afghanistan opened back up,
the radios turned back on
and who comes out of them?
[inaudible] so Greg, when you turn on the radio today in Kabul,
do you hear I'm in Zaire,
I'm telling you it's my main way that I connect with taxi drivers and variably
they're listening to nods. I hear song even now. Oh yeah. Why?
Because there's just nothing
been a chance for new artists to emerge or it's just, you know,
it was a deep freeze.
And also I would say he reminds everybody of what cobble used to be.
I had this experience with my accordion again and again myself.
Even when I played people in my music,
they get this smile on their face as if I was reminding them of something they
knew before me. In fact,
there was one time I was up north and there was this big music festival and I
had brought my accordion and they said, well, why don't you play? And I said,
well, I mean I could play for you. Sure. And they said, how bout right now?
And so they kick the band is on their off. They send them to drink green tea,
they shoved me up on stage. I'm standing in front of 300 Afghans.
And these guys,
they're not from Cabo, they don't speak English,
they're not wearing suits and ties. This is a very Afghan crowd.
So I figure I should play some Johnny Cash.
Lauren
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] do you was the best crowd I've ever had.
[inaudible]
Greg Warner traveled to Afghanistan with support from an international reporting
project fellowship from the John Hopkins School of Advanced International
Studies. And if you visit our website, radiolab.org you can see
video, actual video footage of that Johnny Cash concert.
It's worth checking out each. She shot it.
So there you see them all in their strange non-country Western clothing.
Well we should, we're out. We're out of time. When you're on our website,
radiolab.org you can also send us an email radio lab@wnyc.org I'm Jad Abumrad.
I'm Robert Krulwich. Thanks for listening.